thank you for the most a million and
what I'll try to what L speak about now
is some very basic and problems and
we'll examine the sample complexity of
this so not surprisingly i will talk
about my national policies differential
privacy now go over not go where the
definition but just to make sure i'm
talking about epsilon delta differential
privacy sometimes i will try to
sometimes i'll only take about absent
official policy this means the delta is
zero and a central problem too privacy
is this what is the price of privacy and
actually it's a question of trade-off
between resources how much utility can
we get how much privacy can you get what
is the data size and so on and in this
total just pick about this triangle of
utility privacy number of samples and
this will be in a restricted context of
learning private learning and sanitizing
okay the top plan is very simple I will
begin with the a to a little more
applications so some questions and then
i will present the main tool which is
i'll define what a concave from its
problems are and i'll give a tool for
solving them and using a few samples
this is going to be the task and then
i'll end up in some are even give you an
open problem okay so my focus is going
to be on intervals but before
introducing intervals i want to
introduce even a simpler concept class
and this is the concept class of point
functions what's nice about points point
function is that we buy now i think we
know almost everything that we want to
know about
out these in terms of learning and
scientist Asian the domain is always
going to be parameterized x by d and the
domain size due to the d and point
function is just simply a function that
evaluates to 1 on just one point of the
domain in interval so maybe I should
have called them threshold functions are
functions that evaluate to 1 on the
interval from 0 to J and then devaluate
20 okay and we have to do d plus one
such function in interval d now what r
this task the first task is learning and
this was a private learning was defined
in a John paper with Adam and Cynthia
and Shiva and who mean but in order to
avoid four meters and what's up what's
India you should see ya oh I should have
said Sophia okay sorry so sorry you
should have been and also but so the
paper focuses on pack learning but just
to save time and parameters I will
notify impact learning I will define
learning in a much restricted sense so
private learner is an algorithm that
preserve differential privacy epsilon
delta and if the sample is consistent
with some interval functions example is
a collection of pearls xiy I or why is a
0 0 1 and this is the main element if
the sample is consistent with some
interval function then we require that
with high probability we will output an
interval function that is almost
consistent with the sample okay so I
don't care about interesting with the
underlying distribution just for
simplicity okay and the sanitization
task is a bit different here the sample
is not labeled or just
election of points and we want to
provide differential privacy and the
outcome should be a database again a
collection of points such that for any
interval worry if we evaluate it on the
database the original database or if we
evaluate it on the site as their base
the difference is not that big and alpha
is going to be the accuracy parameter
for both the learning and sanitizing
tasks and there's another parameter
which is better the probability that
we're going to fail what I'm going to
forget about this pointer in order to
save on like just messing up the slides
and it's very useful even the intervals
is a very simple concept class because
we can use the Site other for computing
medians and the polarizer and so on now
why do we know if we restricted for
epsilon differential privacy um here we
know pretty much everything would like
to know about this a questions it is the
main size of sight age 22 the D then
four points we know that we can learn
them using about these samples and this
is also needed there's a load on so this
is the positive result in negative
result with the chibok Assyrians were
not a nanotube a man a similar thing
happens for sanitization and but this
slow body is only for proper learning so
if you insist on out putting your point
function if you relax the requirement
and you allow outputting any function
and then this is called improper
learning and it turns out that you can
reduce the sample complexity to a
constant ok and for intervals the same
holds for proper learning actually about
the same construction and lower bounds
and for sanitization and recently
batali felon david shall show that also
for improper learning the sample
complexity has to be high okay so
learning intervals without privacy only
requires although fun samples okay and
overall the picture is relatively closed
on with respect to epsilon differential
privacy what happened we have a theorem
that gives a characterization of the
sample complexity of epsilon
differentially private learners in terms
of this construct that is called the
representation dimension you can think
it's something analogous to the data
mentioned for regular don't private
clinic so roughly we know everything
would like to know about the case of
epsilon differential privacy would
respect to learning okay so let's get
back to our main task we want to learn
intervals I will not show the sanitizers
but the main ideas that are used for the
learner also applied for the sanitizer
just that we need a few more tools there
and so this is our task I restated it we
are looking for this J that maximizes
that driven to both the data set okay
and this is a typical data set and I
don't know what to do with this so
suppose are now a little bird comes and
tell me tells me gives me a hint and it
tells me there is a for good interval
here and it will give me the interval
what is for good interval it's an
interval that contains a lot of ones and
a lot of zeros but every interval that
is significantly shorter than it like x
factor for either it doesn't contain too
many ones or it doesn't contain too many
zeros ok I will qualify exactly what
this means later on but if this bird
comes and tells me that this is such an
interval that I'm already dead I'm
already done so Gee Gee is a for good
inter Valley if you look at the shorter
intervals
no where you can catch both many ones
and many zeros ok there's waits for good
ok why are we done so this is an
innocent of ideas that appear in in
other places I think also in your work
with junior so if we divide G into our
four equal intervals and we look at this
equally spread concepts refresh all
functions then one of them is going to
be good we can output it and this
doesn't affect price privacy because
it's only post processing and we can use
like we can choose one of these using a
variety of mechanisms for instance a
expansion mechanism and we only need a
small number of samples to do this ok
but we don't have a for good interval so
let's ask the bird again and now the
bird gives us another hint it tells us
there is a to good interval of length j
ok how can we use that so actually this
may be at first it seems very maybe
bizarre of the bird who gives this kind
of a hint but if you think about the
problem of learning intervals ultimately
you get to the point where you need to
hold some scale factor of scale value of
the problem you need to know where you
have enough points that are both zero
and both one and and the main issue is
in finding such an interval ok so this
bird gives us now this the scale the
scale value how can we use it is very
simple we can divide the axis into this
intervals of length to j and then
without there exist to do the interval
so it's contained in at least one of
these intervals
so here so it's contained a three and
then we can use like distance to
stability kind of techniques in order to
find this interval so it's easy once we
know this information okay good and this
is how we construct a for good interval
so we don't need the first build only
this bird is is needed to know now but I
don't have a bird so how can I do this
by myself I can search for the length J
and here's a naive way of doing this I
will try a binary search but this will
require order of this sample so I'm not
getting anything beyond Epsom
differential privacy second attempt is
to know that you we don't really need to
look at all the J's all the lengths it's
enough that we look at say powers of two
and then we're just annoys complexity to
allegories making tea okay so can we do
better ok so I'll step back now and I
will restate the problem and abstract it
to what I'll call convex promise problem
and then concave originally first called
by mistake index don't even from his
problems and let me tell you what is a
concave function this is actually the
quasi concave this is weaker than
Kincaid q is a quasi concave if you look
at three are I lnj world Elias between
I&J then q @ l is at least a minute we
knew a tie on gog and it's very easy to
see that the intervals function here is
contained and we can define a concave
promised problem to have this for input
first it's a sensitivity one function I
quality function and interval of
solutions we will need to pick a
solution some promise are we'll see
news what that means an approximation
parameter and then we only require to
give a good answer if the promise is in
the true so if Q is concave and there
exists some point on which q is at least
are okay then we need to give up the
point in the range so that we're not
that far from from the promise don't
look at such a queue and how can we try
please solve it recall that what we're
interesting interested in now is a low
subcomplex city okay just suppose again
the bird comes and he tells us this the
lengths are J such that there is a
exists in interval so that within that
interval a queue is always high it's
very close to all but outside that
interval here so like the green a green
interval is is like that but outside if
we look at the intervals of fur twice
the size then there is at least one
point where Q is not that high and
because of will have noise then there's
going to be some overlap between not too
high or not that high and high enough
and not that high that's fine once we
have that then we can apply tricks
similar to what we did earlier with the
bird there exists a point with a high
quality so consider the interval around
eight of size for JSON these two
intervals p1 p2 each of size 2 d.j so in
both of them there exists points where
the quality is not that high and because
the function is concave if we go to the
left or to the right from these points
the quality can only deteriorate and and
so we get the interval the good interval
that we have that is contain
and NP okay and again we can use the
same trick in order to to find this
interval okay but now we have to find
this jae and this abstraction in to
contain promised problems will help us
so given this concave function q 0 given
Q maybe it's not okay we can define this
function so we look at all LJ is a
maximum over all intervals of size 2 to
the J of the minimum quality in that
interval okay and you can see that it's
a monotone clean on increasing function
it has the maximum is on zero because we
have the promises at least our and hence
there exists some point J where l is lfj
is high but LF j plus 1 is slightly
below one myself over 2 times 0 okay
because of this morning motto new city
and we're looking for this j so i just
copied what we know so far and now we
are going to do the trick will define a
new comp concave problem and you concave
function based on l and we will then
because we know how to solve concave a
problems and I from compromise photos
via a caution will be able to workers
and and find Jay so look at this here of
jay is is a minimum kind of a window
like require we look at LJ minus 1 up 1
over alpha R and R minus l j plus 1 so
remember that there is this good point
where LJ a is more than one myself over
two times R and L
any plus 1 is less than 1 minus 12 over
2 hour and then from that we get that
there exists this J where the qualities
is high ok so we reduced the promise by
a factor of alpha over 2 and it's easy
to show that Q itself is concave
actually regardless whether the original
q was concave it's always concave but we
can apply recursion the promise is
reduced by a factor of Arthur the two
and the truck in recursion depth is log
star of d ok why is that because we
reduced the from t2 optic the wrench ok
this is what we gain and so what does
this give us the sample complexity is
going to be 2 to the order of log
starting the reason it's 22 the order of
log stardate because we are losing a
factor of f of a tool here every time we
applied with caution ok let me give you
a more complete statement what we get is
a learner four intervals with sample
complexity and I removed some factors
from this here this is the stamp of
complexity to to the order of log star d
/ of epsilon times log 1 over delta we
also get the sanitizer for intervals
with simple complexity that is similar
that we get a worse dependence on alpha
here and so these results look nice
theoretically would like them also to be
nice practically but the problem is that
were the constants that we have there
although this looks like a very slow
going slowly growing function when you
plug in the numbers you get something
bad and also this factor of log 1 over
Delta is quite large
but if we stop the recursion after at
depths k we get something different
slightly different and we analyze
privacy using a less and less good
composition theorem then and we get that
the sample complexity looks like log log
log K times of of D plus a constant
times log 1 over Delta if K is small
then this constant is going to be small
the constants is explanation inkay some
but this could be a much better choice
for particle users if everybody if
anybody is going to implement this as a
result suction this work yeah
so in the paper we have some odd results
actually we started with the question of
learning points and we observed at using
PTR where you can learn points with just
order of one samples independent of D of
D we have learns for K points for axis
aligned rectangles and Santana's four
points and K points and intervals okay
okay let me summarize there's a very
rich picture with respect to private
learners I it's quite surprising would
absolute privacy learning is fully
characterized by a visitation dimension
and but also already they are just an
interesting picture because there is
this difference between proper and
improper learning and importer learning
gives us a lot of power there at least
in some cases not because of computation
rings of computation but reasons of
information okay the privacy is what
makes the difference there's a dramatic
difference between properly prepare
learning I just said that and when you
move to from epsilon epsilon Delta
differential privacy again there seems
to be a dramatic difference because the
sample complexity can drop dramatically
we gave an efficient epsilon data
private for interval the I didn't
discuss the wrong time but you can show
each polynomial actually if you look at
the recursion mechanism after one step
you were just the range from T to lock
key so after the first recursion you can
actually do everything is okay
exhaustively so the only question is
whether you can do the first step
efficiently okay and this is helpful
because we don't really understand what
these strange functions like down the
recursion mean but we do understand the
quality in the first step and so on this
separation and the tools that we use
is PTR and the recursive algorithm
another algorithm that I don't have time
to talk about but you can look in the
paper we call it the choosing makers
mechanism but still and the question is
open what is a real sample complexity of
this of these tasks in particular can
one show that the sample complexity is
super constant ok we know that it cannot
be that high but can it drive it down to
be a constant here I'll finish thank you
is it coming from charitable on sturdy
or is it coming from the other so it's
22 the order log study so there is a big
constant there now I think 16 or somehow
you do we think we can rub it down to
something close to four we didn't do all
the work in order to do that so it can
be reduced I'm not sure it will be
practical it even after that reduction
ok other freshmen
all right lunchtime see ya